et alors aujourd'hui c'est halloween
vous avez déjà une expérience
paranormale vous rendez vous est déjà
arrivé un truc de fou par exemple le m à
gagner non c'est pas un truc de fou sait
jamais 6-6 a déjà fait fumer un fantôme
quoi là on en a et moi je viendrai
raboter l'histoire maintenant rigolo pas
parce que ces dix heures de matin et les
moteurs en montagne en tombant dans la
montagne et jour et à le présenter
si c'est pour le non mais c'est castany
parce que là non parce qu'on part de
leurs chantiers démarrent à pavie qu'on
en rigole je conjure à quoi tu le sais
pas si on a raté des paquets sont tus
neige
si les terriers c'est même pas la peine
à toi voilà connais ce qui le pousse
alors de non non je croyais et c'est
pour ça que j'étais sûr que tu nous
piéger
tu peux te venger de ce qu'on a fait et
de ce fait non que vous m'avez le plus
haut rhin avec raoult et avec siemens a
crevé à tu sais moi je vais tactique et
tout le monde va dire o'neal qui a
remonté que jamais les couilles oui et
on rigole pas non alors non mais c'est
le cas alors on rigole pas non moi si je
tenais donc ma tante et y être longtemps
elle est morte parce qu'elle est tombée
de la montagne un peu chiant en
escaladant la montagne et joue on a des
signes et je sais pas on était enfant
est mon frère à babylone côté c'est fini
c'est père non mais non c'est non c'est
terminé maintenant rigoler
messire nombreux savants et rooney
regarde moi ces phénomènes qui d'avoir
été ses caméras cachées wade la prod
quitte à s'engueuler parce que je suis
sûr que c'est un piège de la prod
oui ils le feraient trop bien avait
franchement ouais mais est ce que tu
m'as vu - faire de conneries parce que
je sais faire des coups a déjà tout le
monde a joué devant lequel veut jauge de
la libye j'étais sûr que c'est un piège
du pugilat
alors est-ce que quoique quand tu l'a
démarrée genre ouais je vous la raconte
mais vous rigolez pas j'ai mis c'est sûr
c'est la preuve que quand même que ça
toujours la famille pas d'inversion
alors vas-y et n'en savait pas que c'est
vrai dans cette histoire c'est une vraie
histoire d'accord est morte et quatre t4
sont surtout es tout seul à la maison
avec mon frère ma belle soeur ma femme
cheryl moi je te le dis voilà mais c'est
bien
affaire invite comment ça n'a pas plu
c'est une base annuelle à 12 tout les
visiteurs famille oui non oui ça il ya
posé des questions au sommet alors
mettez la bête pour finir on a eu une
attaque
la soeur de ma mère dans ma tête et qui
est morte et ses cognacs et vous le
ferez cheyrou tous faut savoir si j'ai
encore une connerie tu arrives in fi
gratuit 3 de koh lanta
et est-ce qu'il y aura de la dumars en
dessous non elle fume on les habitue
veut fumer ou un ami l'a serré à droite
et la seat l'habitat s'était plaint de
nicotine alors vous en ferez
l'expérience vous verrez si moi je dis
des conneries
voilà maintenant est donc tout à fait
vrai mais erronée je te jure j'étais
persuadé qu'il succéderait histoire mais
c'est une vraie leçon et comme elle
fumait matin précise anne au lieu dit le
deuxième prénom d'isabelle exactement tu
veux fumer est la mairie tout et on a
mis la cité garate owona et tu voyais
comment capter et l'afld le fanatique
tafita 7ème art aux attaques avortées à
la maison essayez mettais mes cigares
commence à vouloir lui mais où la météo
et puis vous verrez et kata soit consumé
mais la soute à ce sera pas d'accord
sacré son charme
[Rires]
non mais vous vous êtes rentrer en
contact avec un fantôme ouais là c'est
vrai aussi maintenant je veux convaincre
personne il se trouve que en étant
vacant chez mon oncle qui prêtre qui est
curé à l'andalousie en fait mais c'est
la même famille est en fête
il nous avait prêté une maison de
village et en rentrant le soir avec mes
frères et je vois vraiment quelqu'un
devant nous qui monte les escaliers
alors évidemment lui courent derrière
mon frère l'avait pas vu avec moi qui
l'ait vu je cours derrière pearson rien
et c'est arrivé comme ça peut être soit
éco commandes est en fait et en fait
mais mon frère m'avait dit surtout tu
dis pas à tonton parce qu'il va mal le
prendre
qui est quelqu'un comme ça chez lui on
l'a vraiment vu physiquement vraiment la
vue donc moi évidemment être ma grande
gueule locaux mais attendez pas finie et
moi et ma grande gueule je le décris
physiquement amont donc à table un
déjeuner ce qui était évidemment
interdite par mon frère aîné et et mon
nom que se lève tranquillement donc le
prête il se laisse tranquillement il va
chercher une photo et il sourit me dis
c'est pas lui la archives [ __ ] oui je
dis à mon frère regardes tu vas que
c'est lui je n'ai pas je ne pouvais pas
savoir et en fait c'était l'enfant de
choeur enfin pas d'enfant de cours par
semaine un sacristain le mec s'occuper
de l'église et qui s'était pendu dans la
chambre là oh oui oui j'ai bien vu la
deuxième étape est souvent mais ce cas
tout raconté folle envie d'en face au
oui non mais j'ai des trucs terribles
mais moi j'ai je vois des choses toute
façon c'est vrai oui vraiment
sérieusement mais je veux convaincre
personne mais je vois beaucoup de choses
vous avez vu quelque chose sur quelques
indices
j'ai vu que j'allais être viré
prochainement
[Rires]
connais tu crois quoi cette histoire a
bien sûr mais moi si je suis pas une
incroyable un athée je suis ce qu'on
appelle un agnostique que tu veux dire
je crois pas mieux pas tu ne peux pas
prouver qu'ils existent mais ils voient
gagnants parce que je m' a prouvé qu'ils
n'existent pas c'est cet agnostique
voilà c'est tout et quand je vois des
plus que peut pas en amont parce que je
me rends compte de ça m'est arrivé plein
de trucs eh ben je vis avec voilà vous
étiez vous dans mes tournées je suis
tombé un jour dans une vieille abbaye
qui était transformé en hôtel et le
maître le mec qui nous reçoit et dire je
vous mettre dans la chambre du maître
quoi donc dans la vieille abbaye et
c'était des rideaux rouges machin que je
sache épuisé un g320 dans les guiboles
je m'endors avant de toucher l'oreiller
toi et ensuite je sens que quelqu'un qui
me dit ne restent pas là mais comme ça
toi avec une une colère toi je t'aime je
sauvais yeux j'allume la lumière j'y
tiens c'est un petit peu bizarre
bon ça va j'ai dû dormir mais avec les
lumières allumées
ouais au cas où tu vois sur paris à
peine je repars je ressens mais comme si
on me secret comme si on disait qu est
ce que je t'ai dit je trouve à nouveau
les yeux je téléphone à mon chauffeur
qui est dans une chambre dans la partie
neuve qui lui va très bien et j'ai dit
je sais quoi on va retourner à la
réception parce que il ya trop de monde
dans ma chambre et donc je voudrais
déménager j'arrive à la réception et le
le gardien il a un sourire comme ça il
me dit je vous attendais je savais que
vous allez revenir parce que cette
chambre
c'est la chance du maître de maison des
trucs
il a été les morts dans des conditions
violentes assassiné et il habite
toujours
lieux et ma gueule lui revenait pas
sûrement et donc j'ai changé de chambre
et après j'ai dormir tranquille j'ai
vécu vraiment ce à quoi je pense que
quand jean marie raconte une histoire
on s'attend tout de même à voir une
histoire et pirola et puis il y croit
dur comme fer à tous ces trucs là
présent minibar après ils l'auront allez
merci jean mendez